[Musique]
je n'ai d'une petite région et en plus
j'avais une famille extraordinaire
mes parents m'ont soutenu toute ma vie
oui j'ai un fort caractère mais je
pensais pas que j'allais décembre aussi
beau
[Musique]
au fil de mauvaises rencontres et de
trahison cette fille comme les autres
attiré par montréal la grande ville
tombe sous le charme d'un manipulateur
un proxénète
il m'a regardé comme si j'étais la
septième merveille du monde j'étais
vraiment dépendante affective
en fait ça se résume parce que j'étais
j'ai subi beaucoup d'intimidation à
l'école je voulais toujours me faire
aimer
j'avais besoin d'amour vulnérables en
plus d'être chômeuse après avoir perdu
son emploi de serveuse
tous les ingrédients sont là pour que
s'amorce sa lente descente en enfer
quand j'ai commencé à le faire j'essaye
avec un gars puis je me suis rendu
compte que c'était un type
moi j'avais 24 heures je pensais que je
te plus intelligente que ça m'arriverait
pauvre celui qu'elle pensait être un
protecteur deviendra son bourreau lui il
me disait que je t'ai sa femme à lui que
les autres c'était juste pour l'argent
que moi j'étais là parce qu'il m'aimait
quand il commence à prendre presque tout
l'argent qu'elle gagne en se prostituant
elle perd le contrôle
l'exploitation sexuelle s'installe
ce rebelle en sort il était intoxiqué il
y avait but maudit d'autres ou
d'attitude ça marche pour hymne au
violet c'est là que j'ai compris que je
pouvais plus retourner en arrière
j'étais vraiment rendu bois très bas
après se bat pour prendre encore plus
d'emprise sur moi il demandait à ses
amis soir si tu veux coucher avec elle
puis m'obliger à avoir des relations
avec ses amis c'est de l'esclavagé
moderne
c'est clairement ce la manipulation
c'est de la violence verbale physique
puis la verbale a fait mal aussi parce
que quand tu es rendu avant ton corps tu
veux dire que tu es juste une [ __ ]
ça fait mal ce qui m'a empêché de partir
vraiment c'était 2-1 la peur moi dans le
fond ce tome le zeste du porte voix de
faire violer
soit deux phares wollitz votre fard
battre par miami
j'étais comme son objet j'étais rendu un
objet elle finit quand même par s'enfuir
puis quand je suis parti il a commencé à
écrire des petits mots d'amour
moi je suis rien sans toi c'était
horrible faut comprendre que tout pas de
logique pas d'argent tôt rien pantoute
je suis reparti vers lui parce que je me
disais c'est ma faute si elle n'est pas
bien
puis quand charvet à l'hôtel était avec
un autre homme
puis là il me dit de new services parce
que je dois de l'argent c'est un peu de
ta faute
le j'ai vraiment compris que ça
changerait pas je me suis sentie
séquestrés tu fais quoi tu appelles tu
la police d escorte
c'est dans ce temps là je savais pas que
c'était pas illégal que les policiers
allaient pas m'arrêter parce que je t'ai
escorte
malgré ces craintes elle décide de
chercher de l'aide
les policiers ont vraiment été correcte
pour de vrai là on tisse un tissu social
autour de moi il m'a envoyé vers les
organismes y m'ont fait aider la cavac
m'a vraiment aidé c'est le centre d'aidé
aux victimes d'actes criminels
le défi c'est la coordination entre les
corps policiers et les organismes dead
puisque les victimes de la traite des
personnes sont souvent déplacés entre
les provinces d'une ville à l'autre et
pas seulement dans les grands centres
elle a porté plainte contre son
proxénète et à témoigner contre lui lors
du procès si on a une déclaration de la
victime
si on a de la preuve suffisante
on peut poser des accusations et
potentiellement avoir des condamnations
et donc enlever un peu le fardeau à la
victime de démontrer son agression et là
c'est le hawk saynètes où le trafiquant
qui a le devoir de montrer qu'il ne vit
pas des fruits de la traite des
personnes donc un renversement du
fardeau qu'on met sur les criminels et
non pas sur les victimes le bourreau de
la survivante a été reconnu coupable de
la traite des personnes
il a écopé de plusieurs années de prison
au delà des procédures légales
elle se reprend en main avec le soutien
du cavac
ça a été dur moi j'avais plus destin
personnel j'avais un gros choc post
traumatique
j'ai décidé que ce que j'avais vécu ce
n'est pas pour brimer ma vie toulon j'ai
arrêté de consommer elle aspire à une
vie normale
la priorité c'est les ressources qu'on
met à la disposition des victimes pour
les aider non seulement à sortir des
réseaux de traite
mais surtout à sortir des réseaux de
prostitution
que ce soit des ressources en
hébergement aides psychologiques
monétaire retour au travail retour à
l'école aujourd'hui cette survivante but
éviter que d'autres ne tombent dans le
panneau
il faut en parler à 12 13 ans leur
expliquer un peu ce que c'est parce que
il ya des filles de 12 13 ans qui se
ramasse dans ce nul
et aussi de leur expliquer qu est-ce que
c'est une relation toxique c'est de
travailler leur dépendance affective
aussi parce que quand tu es dépendantes
ses porte-voix tomber mais c'est certain
que tu vas tomber un jour
faut arrêter de mettre la faute sur les
parents le c'est ma mère hamon n'a pas
parlé mais à connaissais pas ça c'est
facile de juger mais c'est de le
comprendre c'est ça le plus dur mais ce
qui est important c'est de le comprendre
parce que faut arrêter de juger ce monde
là
[Musique]